en la última reunión de emergencia del
Consejo de Seguridad de Naciones Unidas
el bloque de los países de occidente
denunció La amenaza que supone Correa
del Norte para la paz internacional
con la mayor firmeza el lanzamiento de
29 misiles incluidos varios misiles
balísticos por parte de Corea del Norte
en los últimos tres días la actual
escalada no tiene precedentes y estas
nuevas provocaciones son inaceptables
pero La retórica de la provocación está
siendo utilizada tanto de un lado como
del otro Rusia y China aliados de Corea
del Norte criticaron los ejercicios
militares conjuntos de Estados Unidos y
Corea del Sur
las recientes actividades de lanzamiento
de Corea del Norte no se han producido
de forma aislada y están directamente
relacionadas con las palabras y acciones
de las partes implicadas tras un
paréntesis de 5 años Estados Unidos y el
país en cuestión ha reanudado sus
ejercicios militares conjuntos a gran
escala en los que participan cientos de
aviones de guerra
estos ejercicios aéreos conjuntos
llamados tormenta vigilantes son los más
grandes que ambas naciones están
llevando a cabo en la región el régimen
de Kim Jong nos ha denunciado como una
maniobra militar agresiva y provocadora
dirigida a la República popular
democrática de Corea y advertido hace
Uli Washington con La amenaza nuclear un
tema que preocupa occidente desde que
Corea del Norte empezó su programa en el